!
>> HE WAS SUPPOSED TO UNITE THE
COUNTRY BUT LATELY ALL IT SEEMS
BIDEN WANTS TO DO IS CREATE
DIVISION.
IT'S A FULL WEEK OF BIDEN'S
RELENTLESS ATTACK ON THE SEMI
FASCIST REPUBLICANS AND IT
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE HE'S GOING TO
TONE IT DOWN ANYTIME SOON.
>> I DON'T RESPECT THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
THEY ARE DESTROYING AMERICA.
IT'S BECAUSE I DON'T BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY.
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS, AND
CONGRESS.
FOR THOSE BRAVE RIGHT-WING
AMERICANS WHO SAY IT'S ALL ABOUT
SHAPING AMERICA AND KEEPING
AMERICA INDEPENDENT AND SAFE.
DO YOU WANT TO FIGHT FOR THE
COUNTRY, YOU NEED SOMETHING MORE
THAN A GUN.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW
THAT'S BIDEN CROSS THE LINE WHEN
THE MEDIA IS UPSIDE.
>> AND MAKES OBVIOUSLY PERFECT
SENSE FOR SOMEONE LIKE THE
SENATOR, BECAUSE WHEN
NEW HAMPSHIRE MORE THAN 40% OF
THE VOTERS WERE INDEPENDENT.
ANOTHER 30 AND CHANGE ARE
REPUBLICANS.
SO SHE NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO REACH
OUT AND THE LANGUAGE DOESN'T
HELP.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU CAN
ALWAYS FIND ONE CHEERLEADER AND
HERE'S JOY REID COMING TO
BIDEN'S RESCUE.
>> JOE BIDEN IS THE MOST
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD PRO-POLICE,
WORKING CLASS, YOU KNOW,
INOFFENSIVE PURPOSELY
INOFFENSIVE POLITICIAN IN OUR
GENERATION.
>> Judge Jeanine: BIDEN'S JUST
GETTING STARTED IN AND EXPECT TO
HEAR MORE OF THE NASTY ATTACKS
TOMORROW NIGHT FOR HIS SOUL OF
THE NATION SPEECH.
ALL RIGHT, GREG, NOW THAT YOU'RE
BACK, I THINK I'LL GO TO YOU
FIRST.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT WAS THAT
HE SAYS YOU WANT TO FIND AGAINST
THE COUNTRY, YOU NEED AN F-15,
YOU NEED SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT
MORE THAN A GUN.
FIRST OF ALL, IT'S A LITTLE
TONE-DEAF GIVEN THAT WE WHERE AT
A ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY HAVING
LEFT AFGHANISTAN AND LEAVING
F-15s FOR THE TALIBAN, BUT
WHAT WAS HE TALKING ABOUT?
>> Greg: WITH THAT LOGIC, WHY
ARE WE GIVING ARMS OR HER MONEY
TO UKRAINE?
ISN'T THAT USELESS IF YOU'RE
AGAINST A SUPERIOR ARMY?
HIS LOGIC, WE SHOULD GIVE UP ALL
OF OUR RIGHTS, PROTECTIONS
BECAUSE THERE IS NO MATCH FOR
GOVERNMENT FORCE.
RIGHT?
IT'S A SICK BOAST, IT'S NOT SEMI
FASCIST, IT'S FULL ON FASCIST.
WHO KNEW JOE WOULD BECOME A
WARTIME PRESIDENT, BUT HE IS
WAGING WAR ON PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT'S FUNNY HOW -- OKAY, WE
WERE -- JOY REID'S PLAYING THE
GAME MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD.
HE'S AN EMPTY VESSEL THAT THEY
FILL WITH LEFT WING EDGE
PROPAGANDA.
WE THOUGHT HE'S JUST A NICE GUY
AND THEN WE FORGET THIS IS THE
GUY THAT SAID MITT ROMNEY WOULD
PUT BLACK PEOPLE IN CHAINS.
REMEMBER THAT?
THE THING ABOUT JOE, LOOK AT HIS
PAST, HE OPERATED ON THE MOST
TIME SO MIKE MEMORABLE HOT TAKE.
IF YOU SAID SOMETHING, HE GO
FURTHER OUT THERE AND SAY HE IS
GOING TO PUT YOU IN CHANGE.
HE SAYS THE CRAZIEST STUFF.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SUFFERING
FROM IS OLD MAN SYNDROME.
IT'S WHEN YOU ASCRIBE CERTAIN
GENTLENESS TO PEOPLE AS THEY
AGE, I NOTICED MY HAIR HAS GROWN
GRAIN, BABIES LIKE ME, THEY
THINK I'M HARMLESS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT INMATES, OLDER
INMATES, YOU FEEL BAD FOR THEM
AND GO THAT GUY WOULDN'T HURT A
FLY.
WHILE 30 YEARS FROM NOW HE
MURDERED A FAMILY AND OF COURSE
NOW HE'S GOT SALT AND PEPPER
HAIR, HE LOOKS LIKE HAROLD,
EVERYTHING'S OKAY.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH JOE.
JOE HASN'T GOTTEN NICER, HE'S
GOTTEN ANGRIER.
>> Judge Jeanine: DANA, WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF CRITICIZING
HALF THE NATION AND BASICALLY
SAYING THAT REPUBLICANS,
73 MILLION OF THEM WOULD VOTE
FOR DONALD TRUMP, MAGA THIS,
MAGA NOT.
PLANTING A SEED THAT ANY THING
MAGA RELATED IS HORRIBLE AND
THEY'RE THE MOST EXTREME THREAT
TO THE DEMOCRACY AND FREEDOM.
SAYING HE'S NOT GOING TO SHY
AWAY FROM SAYING THE TRUTH.
>> Dana: THE TIMING OF THIS
SAYS TO ME -- THE TIMING
TOMORROW NIGHT HE'S GOING TO
GIVE THE SPEECH AND TELEGRAPHING
THROUGHOUT AUGUST.
PRETTY A SLEEPY MONTH FOR NEWS,
EVERYBODY'S ON VACATION.
PEOPLE AREN'T PAYING ATTENTION.
IT TOMORROW NIGHT IS A THURSDAY
NIGHT BEFORE LABOR DAY WEEKEND,
NOT LIKE PRIME TIME VIEWING.
I THINK THIS IS A TRIAL BALLOON
BY THE STAFF TO SEE IF HE CAN
MAKE THIS MESSAGING STICK.
IF HE DOES, THEY'LL TRY IT'S
BECAUSE THEY MUST HAVE SOME SORT
OF POLLING THAT TELLS THEM IT
WORKS.
BUT THE POLL DOESN'T MATTER AND
LOOK AT 2016.
THAT WAS REALLY A DEFINING
MOMENT FOR HILLARY CLINTON AND
PEOPLE WANTED SOMETHING NEW.
IF HE IS GOING TO RUN AGAIN, YOU
HAVE TO RUN ON SOMETHING NEW,
EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE HAD TO GO FROM MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN TO KEEP AMERICA
GREAT EVEN THOUGH MAGA STUCK,
BUT THERE WAS A NEED TO SAY I
STILL HAVE SOMETHING NEW AND I
HAVE SOMETHING GOOD COMING.
YOU HAVE TO STAY TUNED FOR THE
NEXT THING.
ALL THEY HAVE IS TO BE AGAINST
THE REPUBLICANS AND THAT MIGHT
WORK IF YOU WANT TO MAKE THE
ELECTION A CHOICE BETWEEN BIDEN
AND THE DEMOCRATS VERSUS B6
IN THE REPUBLICANS RATHER THAN A
REFERENDUM.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
HAROLD, IT KIND OF TAKES THE
TARGET OFF OF THEM AND BAD
POLICIES ENDED FOCUSES ON THE
REPUBLICANS, BUT HOW DO YOU FIX
THE SOUL OF THE NATION IF YOU
CAN'T STOP CALLING YOUR
OPPONENTS PEOPLE NAMES?
>> Harold: GLAD YOU'RE BACK,
WELCOME BACK.
COUPLE OF THINGS COME A OF
THINGS.
I LISTEN TO ALL THE NAMES THAT
WE CALL EVERYBODY.
BIDEN HAS BEEN CALLED A
SOCIALIST, WEAK, SENILE,
MARXIST, COMMUNIST, ONE U.S.
SENATOR SAID HE SENILE AND HE
SHOULD RESIGN.
THE VICTORY HAS BEEN CALLED
ILLEGITIMATE.
IF WE GET SENSITIVE ABOUT NAME
CALLING, THEN POLITICS IS IN THE
BUSINESS YOU SHOULD BE IN.
I EXPECT THE PRESIDENT TO
CONTINUE TO SAY AND SUPPORT LINE
ORDER.
THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE CAMPAIGN AND
VOTERS I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT,
JUDGE, DANA, BUT VOTERS AT SOME
POINT WILL ASK WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO FOR ME GOING
FORWARD?
I THINK DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THEY
WERE THE INCUMBENTS THE OTHER
PARTY WILL HAVE TO SAY THIS IS
WHAT'S WE'RE GOING TO DO TO
DISPLACE YOU AND MAKE YOUR LIFE
BETTER.
YOU SAID LAST WEEK I WAS
CRITICAL OF CHARLIE CREST.
NOT BECAUSE I WANTED HIM TO
APOLOGIZE TO RON DeSANTIS, BUT
APOLOGIZE TO THE VOTERS BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO LAY OUT WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO TO MAKE LIFE BETTER
FOR THE VOTERS.
MOST OF THE THINGS I HEAR
REPUBLICANS SAY ARE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE HUNTER BIDEN,
JANUARY 6 OVER AGAIN, AND
INVESTIGATE -- THEY WANT TO
INVESTIGATE.
SOME TOOK AN INTERESTING FUN
THING TO DO, BUT I'M NOT SURE
IT'S A WINNING MESSAGE.
SPEECH OR CAN COMPARE
GOING AFTER JOE BIDEN LIKE GOING
OFF AFTER VOTERS.
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S THE
QUESTION FOR BRIAN.
ONE THING TO GO AFTER JOE BIDEN
WHO SENILE, AND ANOTHER THING
SAYING WE'RE TRYING TO DESTROY
MAGA REPUBLICAN IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Brian: YOUR SHORT-TERM
MEMORY IS VERY STRONG.
I DON'T FEEL BAD, NEVER HAVE.
KIM ON THE NOWHERE.
I DON'T FEEL FOR THEM AND I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THEY DID.
>> Greg: DON'T THEY LOOK
GRANDFATHERLY?
>> Brian: THAT'S NOT WHERE I
CHOOSE TO GIVE MY FREE TIME.
YOU PUT UP A THING I ALMOST
FORGOT.
THEY DID THE SAME THING.
THEY BOTH SAID I DON'T WANT
RON DeSANTIS SUPPORTERS TO
SUPPORT ME.
I DON'T LIKE YOU.
THEN THE GOVERNOR SAYS I DON'T
WANT CONSERVATIVES TO STAY HERE,
I WANT YOU TO GO TO FLORIDA.
I'VE NEVER HEARD ANYTHING LIKE
THAT.
THE PRESIDENT THE DAY BEFORE
YESTERDAY COMES OUT AND SAYS
WHEN IT COMES TO REPUBLICANS,
MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE BASICALLY
IRREDEEMABLE.
I DON'T WANT ANY PART OF YOU AND
BY THE WAY I'M GOING TO BRING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER IN FRONT OF
INDEPENDENCE HALL TOMORROW.
SORRY IF I DON'T TUNE IN.
HOW SCARY IS THAT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT TURNS AROUND AND WALKS
AWAY FROM THE CAMERA?
REMINDS ME THE END OF TOOTSIE.
LIKE OH, MY GOODNESS, WHAT ARE
THEY GOING TO DO?
I IMAGINE LIKE THE WHOLE STAFF
IS LIKE OH, MY GOD, HE'S WALKING
AWAY AND AD-LIBBING, YOU MIGHT
SAY 15 OR CORN POP IN A MATTER
OF MOMENTS AND WILL HAVE TO WALK
IT BACK.
I FIND A STRATEGY STRANGE.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THICK SKIN IN
THE BUSINESS BUT I FIND THE
STRATEGY STRANGE BECAUSE THE
GOAL IS TO GET AS MANY VOTES AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT TRUMP
UNDERSTOOD.
HE GO AFTER CELEBRITIES,
ATHLETES, EVERYBODY, BUT THE
VOTER YOU LEAVE ALONE.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHO STARTED
IT WITH ALL MY?
HILLARY CLINTON WITH
DEPLORABLES!
NOBODY DID IT FOR HILLARY AND
NOW BI